sind sie die gefolgt bist du sicher
ich habe dich vermisst
charif ein Theaterstück eine
Liebesgeschichte zwischen zwei
palästinensischen Männern
gleichgeschlechtliche Liebe und Empathie
für Palästinenser ein doppeltes tabu für
die von Fundamentalisten und Rassisten
geprägte neue Regierungen Israel auf dem
Platz in Tel Aviv wo regelmäßig gegen
die Regierung demonstriert wird treffen
wir den jüdischen Regisseur Thoma aldubi
er macht sich ernsthafte Sorgen dass
Stücke wie Seins bald verboten werden
könnten
gegen uns ist so gewalttätig und anders
als vor ein paar Jahren schämen sich die
Menschen nicht einmal mehr ganz offen
homophob zu sein aber gerade deswegen
müssen wir Künstler wir Theatermacher
genau diese Themen weiter auf die Bühne
bringen wir müssen über unsere Community
sprechen über Araber über Frauen über
Minderheiten das ist unsere Aufgabe der
Kampf um einen säkularen Staat und die
lgbtq-community ist nur ein kleiner Teil
davon
derselbe Platz am vergangenen Samstag
80.000 Menschen gehen auf die Straße um
gegen die neue rechtsreligiöse Regierung
zu protestieren alle fürchten sie das
Ende des liberalen Israel
[Musik]
wir sind an einem historischen
Wendepunkt in diesem Moment der
Geschichte wird entschieden ob Israel
ein demokratischer fortschrittlicher
Staat bleibt oder zu einem totalitären
und vorsinflutlichen Staat wird Israel
wird keine Theokratie werden Frauen
werden nicht hinten im Bus sitzen und
die lgbtq-gemeinde wird sich nicht
verstecken müssen
Minister anstatt primeminister nennen
sie Netanjahu der wegen Korruption vor
Gericht steht und dem eine
Gefängnisstrafe droht in einer radikalen
Justizreform will seine Regierung nun
Gesetze durchboxen die Politikern mehr
macht bei der Ernennung von Richtern
verleihen um den Tanja hussalz aus der
Schlinge der Justiz zu ziehen
Israel wird niemand über dem Gesetz
stehen auch nicht der Ministerpräsident
doch Netanjahu und sein
Korruptionsprozess meint Anwältin Anat
Ton aschkenasi sein längst nicht mehr
das Hauptproblem er und seine
Koalitionspartner vertreten einen
Populismus und verschwörungsglauben
wonach Gerichte linksliberale
Staatsfeinde sind
wir befürchten dass wenn diese Reformen
durchkommen die der Ministerpräsident
und sein Justizminister anstreben dass
wir uns nicht einmal mehr auf dem
demokratischen Spielfeld befinden werden
nach einer Umfrage unseres Instituts
meinen 57% der Bevölkerung was Israel
brauche sei ein starker Führer der weder
auf das Parlament hört noch auf die
öffentliche Meinung noch auf die Presse
und daher steht hinter der Dringlichkeit
der aufkommenden Protestbewegung die
Angst bald von einem Regime regiert zu
werden
nicht da in den Augen vieler Israelis
ist das neue netanjahu-kabinett ein Wolf
im Schafspelz ein als Liberale
demokratische Regierung getarntes
religiös fundamentalistisches Regime
Polizeiminister
ittermar bin wir stammt aus der
messianischen Siedlerbewegung und
provozierte erst vor zwei Wochen die
Palästinenser mit einem Besuch auf dem
von Muslimen verwalteten Tempelberg
sein Mitstreiter bezahles Modric ist im
Verteidigungsministerium für die nach
internationalem Recht illegalen
jüdischen Siedlungen in den besetzten
Gebieten zuständig er könnte nach der
Justizreform den Siedlungsbau
vorantreiben wie noch nie das
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen Israels
veröffentlichte vor ein paar Tagen einen
Ton mitschnittsmotritz
ich bin zwar ein ultraleichter
rassistischer homophober Faschist stehe
aber zu meinem Wort die Tatsache dass so
fundamentalistische messianische
religiöse nationalistische rassistische
Politiker jetzt in der Regierung sind
die liegt auch daran das Israel wirklich
zutiefst gespalten ist und dass seine
große Anzahl von Parteien die eine
Koalition mit netanjaro bilden könnten
das nicht tut weil er vor Gericht steht
unter anderem wegen Bestechung
der von deutschen Eltern abstammende
Historiker schaut sich fassungslos eine
ältere netanjahorede an in der dieser
noch die unabhängige justizpries genau
die will er nun Schwächen wenn nicht da
stürzen geht es nach netanjahoo soll das
Parlament in Zukunft Entscheidungen des
Obersten Gerichts mit einfacher Mehrheit
abschmettern können das Ende der
Gewaltenteilung
es gibt eine Gruppe von Politikern die
die ganze Macht an sich reißen wollen
sie wollen nicht nur die Gerichte
entmachten jede Körperschaft die auch
nur irgendwie die Macht der Politiker
beeinträchtigen könnte ist heute unter
Beschuss wird geschwächt und politisiert
eine anwaltsdemonstration in Tel Aviv
ohne Kampf werden sie die Unabhängigkeit
der Justiz nicht aufgeben den Protest
der Roben nennen sie ihre
Widerstandsbewegung
streckt eure Schilder in die Höhe
schwenkt eure Flaggen das ist erst der
Anfang und jetzt singen wir die
Nationalhymne
[Musik]
unsere Hoffnung heißt es da ist es ein
freies Volk in unserem Land zu sein
ich denke viel an meine Enkelkinder wo
die jemals ihr Glück finden werden auf
der Welt und ich sag manchmal dass ich
in der Hoffnung lebe
dieser Staat sie nicht zwingt
wegzugehen und Flüchtlinge zu werden
irgendwo wie meine Eltern etwas aus
Deutschland
Rahel steht am Wendepunkt die Demokratie
ist gefährdeter denn je doch die
Protestbewegung hat gerade erst begonnen